[Music]
although there are a few
chapters early on in philip jose farmers
novella the lovers that are set either
on earth
or in transit in space
most of the chapters most of the
text most of the action most of the
character development and certainly the
resolution
of the story are taking place
on the planet of oz again including the
the interactions between the lovers that
furnishes the title
of the story jeanette and hale
so it's important to look at this
setting
particularly since it plays such
an important role in the story itself
in a number of different ways that's
part of what makes this novella
such a great work of literature the
world building that goes into it and how
that meshes into
the characters and the plot and the
action
in a very short relatively speaking
piece of science fiction literature
and there is some discussion about
linguistics
on the part of hal the main character
because he is a jack-of-all-trades
linguist
he is sent along on the expedition to
oz again precisely to help out with the
language and communications
and in chapter five we we have him
in transit learning uh as best as he can
from the previous expeditions accounts
the language of the waggle bugs the
ozigan
natives right and i'm gonna skip over
all of that because we're more
interested in what we could call their
sociology and history
and the evolution of life
on osagan so i'm gonna pick up here
he says cito the land mass in the
southern hemisphere was about the size
though not the shape of africa
and separated from the other by 10 000
miles of
ocean if the wag geologists were correct
had one
once been part of a gowanda land right
which is a
a massive continent but then it drifted
away evolution had taken a somewhat
different path
from that on the other continent and so
here's the first
discussion of evolution there's really
three main
ways in which evolution is going on this
this globe so he says where is the other
continent the northern continent had
been dominated by
insects and their distant cousins the
endoskeletal
pseudo arthropods this land mass had
been very hospitable to
mammals though sigmund knew there was an
abundance
of insect life on it the sentient
species
on abacatu the northern landmass had
been until 500 years ago the wagglebug
on cito it had been a remarkably
human-looking animal their
homo ozigan had developed a culture at a
stage analogous to that of ancient egypt
or babylon and then almost all the human
civilized or savage
savage had perished this had happened
only a thousand years
before the first wogglebug columbus had
landed on their great continent
at the time of the discovery and for two
centuries after the wags had presumed
the indigenes were extinct
but as the [ __ ] colonists began
penetrating the jungles and mountains of
the interior they encountered a few
small groups of
humanoids these had retreated into the
wilderness where they could hide as
successfully as the african pygmies
had hidden before the great rainforests
were cut down
it was estimated there might be a
thousand maybe two thousand scattered
over an area
of a hundred thousand square kilometers
and so
we've got some some world buildings
sketched out here even before
hal reaches the world we've got a
northern island which is dominated by
various
insect species we're going to encounter
a few of them
in the work and the class of
pseudo arthropoda so what are arthropods
if you don't know what this means
well it's it's a uh group that includes
not only
insects but also the arachnids you know
spiders
uh ticks all sorts of other things as
well and the crustaceans and and a few
other
classes as well farmers keeping it
fairly simple
here and then there are the pseudo
arthropoda and this the you know
includes
the waggle bugs but also includes the
la letha who are going to play a major
role in not just the
the love affair with hal and jeannette
she turns out to be one
but also in the prehistory of the
human semi-human human-like
mammal species involved here
so we have insects and pseudoarthropods
at the northern island the southern
islands separated
from a great distance of ocean dominated
by mammals but there's still many
insects there as well as well as the
very important pseudo-arthropod the
lalitha
so there's some interesting discussions
that take place
between hal the human and
fobo the wogglebug who is going to
help to explain to him uh how evolution
takes place here so hal first borrows a
book on evolution
and um fobo explains it and then hal
refuses to believe fobo
you say that a mammalian life originated
from a primaval sea worm
that has to be wrong we know the first
land life form was an amphibian it's
its fins developed into legs it lost its
ability to get oxygen from sea water it
evolved into a reptile
then a primitive mammal then an
insectivorous creature then a presimium
then a simeon and eventually into the
sapient bipedal stage
and then into modern man so this is how
things developed on earth
and phobos says i don't doubt that
things went just as you said
on earth but here evolution took a
different course
here there were three ancestral sebak
takufu that is mother worms
one had hemoglobin bearing blood blood
cells
one copper bearing one vandium bearing
the first had a natural advantage over
the other two but for some reason it
dominated this the southern continent
but not the others we have evidence that
the first also split
early into two lines both of which were
notochords but one of which wasn't
mammalian
anyway all the mother worms did have
fins and these evolved into
limbs and then hail says evolution can't
work that way your scientists have made
a serious a grievous error
after all your paleontology is just
beginning it's only about 100 years old
and then
fobo says you're too tarot centric
hidebound you have anemic imagination
your thought arteries are hardened
consider the possibility there might be
billions of habitable planets in this
universe
and then on each evolution may have
taken slightly or even
vastly different paths the great goddess
nature is an experimenter she'd get
bored reproducing the same thing over
and over wouldn't you
and so as it turns out phobia at least
in the narrative universe of this book
is going to be right except for
one thing the uh
the woggle bugs are not actually
um going to be you know their their
blood is not actually copper
uh you know bearing rather than iron
bearing right
it turns out to be something different
altogether and it's not van diem
either which is going to play a very
important role in the the later part
where there's this conflict going on
but what we've got here is a very
interesting alternative
evolution and that leads to different
ways in which species live
and interact so we've got the woggle
bugs
and why are they called waggle bugs this
is also tied in with the
ozigan idea um
here we go the aborigines resembled
frank baumes the
oz guy right professor wagglebug their
bodies were rather round and their limbs
were skinny in proportion
their mouths were shaped like two broad
and shallow v's one set inside the other
their lips were thick and lobular
actually a waggle bug had four lips each
leg of the two v's being separated by a
deep seam at the connection
once far back on the evolutionary path
those limbs had been modified arms now
they are rudimentary limbs
so disguised as true labial parts and so
functional that
no one could have guessed at their
origin when the wide v and v
mouths opened in a laugh they startled
the terrans they had no teeth but
serrated ridges of jawbone
a fold of skin hung from the roof of the
mouth once the epipharynx it was now a
vestigial upper tongue
it was this organ which gave the
underlying trill to so many ozigan
sounds and gave the human being so much
trouble
reproducing them so we've got here like
an evolutionary
account or natural history account of
the
wazzle bugs um their their appearance
and their their speech
their skins were as lightly pigmented as
hal's and he was a redhead but where his
was pink theirs was a very
faint green copper not iron carried
oxygen in other blood cells or so they
said
that's a very important foreshadowing
right so far they'd
they'd refuse to allow the hijack to
take blood samples and we'll come back
to that in a moment so we have a
description
of their appearance and throughout this
we see that they are
very human-like in many respects they
have apartment complexes they have
developed science
they have their own version of
psychiatrists which
which fobo is right they uh
have liquor joints and places to go and
hang out
bars they have social casts and so
you know we're talking not just about
physical evolution but also the
evolution of
societies and it's not that dissimilar
from that of
earth we find out as well that they are
technologically behind
earth in many respects except for
biological
weapons and the earth invaders as
we're actually going to find out are a
bit worried about that as
it turns out they don't have to be
worried about that but rather something
else that's going to happen
now we also have these oz again
humans and jeanette is
ostensibly the mixture of an os again
indigenous human-like species
and a earth uh you know
space fare a french guy who
lands all the rest of his crew is dead
but he
uh mates with her mother and her aunts
and uh so she's kind of a hybrid at
least we think until we
find out later that she is actually a
lolita one of these
um pseudo-arthropods who
has adapted itself to human beings and
there's a long discussion by fobo
explaining this that he would have
actually gotten uh hal would have gotten
from a book if he had read the book but
jeannette puts him off
of it because she knows it's going to
bring him up
so what we find out is that the
lolitha have actually
brought about a a
a development in pseudo-human
civilization
right so fomo tells this story but he
also says
most of this is speculative it's based
largely on what the few human natives
we've captured in the jungle
have told us but we also discovered
pictographs in a long buried temple
that gave us additional information so
we think our reconstruction
of the history of the lalitha is valid
so what is that history
he says that they became integrated into
pre-human societies
some family and tribes accepted them
others killed them
they resorted to artifice disguise
themselves as human women
a thing not hard to do unless they
became pregnant
and so the lolitha would they develop
this
back and forth interaction with humans
he goes on and he says you'll find quite
a tribal lore about them fables and
myths make them central or peripheral
characters
they were regarded as witches demons or
worse but
with the introduction of alcohol in
primitive times a change for the better
came to the lalitha
alcohol makes them sterile it also makes
them practically speaking immortal
so they remained at the physiological
age of 25.
the long lives of the lalitha resulted
that they're being worshipped as
goddesses sometimes they live so long
they survived the downfall
of mighty nations that had been small
tribes and the lalitha first joined
their groups
they became the repositories of wisdom
wealth and power
religions were established some cultures
outlawed them
the lalitha themselves you know sort of
subverted that and they gained mastery
over their lovers but not over
themselves
they they belonged to a secret society
in the beginning but they split up
they began to identify themselves with
their nations that they ruled and to use
their countries against their the others
the result was assassination struggles
for power and so on
also their influence was technologically
too stabilizing
they tried to keep the status quo in
every aspect of culture
and so the human cultures had a tendency
to eliminate
new and progressive ideas and the people
who espouse them
so this is maybe what led to the
collapse
of the human civilization which the
woggle bugs discover
when they make it to the continent and
this is a collapse that has happened
quite a while ago one other aspect
that's very important about oz again
is there are dangerous insect species
and so
when they're going out to the bar to get
some some liquor
hal is told by fobo that you you should
carry some weapons right so phobo has a
sword
they carry pistols when they go out in
the jungle and why do they do that
because there are lots of insect species
that have evolved some of them mimics so
for example
uh hal and the his gap run into
a something that appears to be like a
hunched over
waggle bug but actually turns out to be
an incredibly dangerous
acid spitting insect that try that
effectively you know disables the gap
burning his eyes and his mouth
and uh almost kills hal as well there
are also
these sort of ant-like creatures that
end up eating
porcelain the gaps corpse up
at first they kill them and then as gal
leaves they eat them all up
and um there's there's a lot of
interesting
other insect species including the one
that that brews
um the the liquor within its belly right
so all of these
are um you know connected and many of
these insect species are
semi-intelligent
and uh they're regarded as essentially
being
kind of vermin that have to be handled
as such
and this brings us then to the final
important discussion about oz again
who's going to control it
after all the earth ships from the
hijack union
they went out there not just on a
mission of discovery or something like
that
they went there ostensibly at least
according to them
this isn't what they tell the woggle
bugs but
to take over there's a mission
to produce a virus similar to the one
that was deployed in the apocalyptic war
referenced earlier on
in the the work
a virus that will attack copper
bearing blood life forms
like the woggle bugs and eliminate them
so
humans can now move in
and take over and we get a few
discussions of this
going going on uh mostly towards the
there's a few references earlier on but
mostly towards the end
and this is part of why the um
the terrans the hijack union people
wanted the blood samples from the ozone
people
right so um he
tells her that he tells um
hal tells jeanette that they have
reached the point
where the techs have made the globin
locking molecule which will cause you
know sort of anemia
and in the copper bearing
ones so he says the virus is already in
production in a week a large enough
supply would be made to fill the
disseminators of six prowler torpedoes
so these torpedoes that would fly around
what we would call drones now
the plan was to release them to wipe out
the city of sito
they would fly in spirals whose range
would expand into a large territory was
covered
as they went out for reloading and went
out again the entire planet of wags
would be
slain that's the plan there
and
here we go there's a little bit more
interesting discussion later on
as all the stuff about the lalitha is
coming to light
um hal is told about project
earth man phobos lips parted in a smile
i can't tell you now because your
colleagues on the gabriel might just
possibly learn about it
before it takes effect however i think i
can tell you that we know about your
plan for spreading the deadly glob and
locking
molecule through our atmosphere hal says
there was a time when i would have been
horrified to learn that but now it
doesn't matter
and then fobo says you don't want to
know how we found out about it and
hal says sure when you asked us for
samples of blood you aroused our
suspicion
we can't read your thoughts but
concealed in this flesh
of his nose are two antennae they are
very sensitive
evolution is not dulled our sense of
smell as it has among uterines
they allow us to detect through odor
very slight changes in the metabolism of
others
when we were asked by one of your
emissaries to donate blood for their
scientific research we smelled a
shall i call it furtive emanation we
finally did give you the blood
but it was the blood of a barnyard
creature which uses copper
in its blood cells we wogs use magnesium
as the oxygen
carrying element in our blood cells our
virus viruses useless
yes of course in time when you'd learned
to read our writing and got hold of our
textbooks
you'd have discovered the truth so
this is very interesting he goes on and
he says
you know we don't really want to do this
but you
earth people have been the aggressor
and our survival was at stake so the
means justified
the ends we captured a biochemist in his
gapped
while they were visiting a laboratory we
injected a drug and hypnotized them
and we got the truth out of them
and so we've got our own plans and those
plans come to
a culmination basically what they end up
doing
is digging underneath the earth
ship when trains are going by so that
there won't be any
detection of the digging and they fill
up the entire compartment underneath the
ship with gun powder
set off an incredibly powerful charge
which causes a shock wave it doesn't
destroy the ship which
of course they want for the technology
but the
shock wave kills everybody inside the
ship
including the people that are ready to
set off a hydrogen bomb
should there be any attempt to take over
the ship which means effectively
not only was the earth hijack union plot
uh revealed uh through this this attempt
to
get blood right but the woggle bugs came
up with their own solution
and very interestingly there's this this
speech that is given
at the very end about um
what they did and why they
did it by fobo so he tells them
here we go we're fairly peaceful
but unlike you terrans we're really
realists
if we have to take action against vermin
we do our best to exterminate them
on this insect ridden planet we have a
long history of battling
killers and he also tells hal i don't
include you among the vermin
you're free to go where wherever you
want to do
what you want hal says you know that's
great i've always wanted freedom but
what's there left for me and fobo
reminds him now that there's actually a
possibility for him
being as he's as hal had suggested to
jeannette before
sort of like the new adam and eve
there's children to be raised the
children of him and jeannette
and there's also jeanette's sisters and
aunts who they can
locate and hal of course is still
grief-stricken
but there's this promise that perhaps
the oz again
humans or a new human amalgam
could in fact become uh the
you know secondary race and live
in proximity with and perhaps even in
society with
the woggle bugs and that's where the
story ends
with this wonderful world building that
has taken place
i think by the way i'll close this this
would be very
ripe for further development
and sequalization i'm sure somebody's
actually done that out there somewhere
but
it's it's a very rich environment this
planet of
oz again
you